大皆の衆
機ミグあるかい
安保がないですものを運んだり働いている時って筋肉とても大事だと思うんですよ壁
ってやっぱりネコどもの筋肉が少なかったり女性の方も筋力がなかったりは僕も決して
男なんですよ金利がある子じゃないんで非常に弱いんですけどそんな皆さんに朗報です
なんとなんとですね
10年の11月からヒール筋肉が発売されました
買ってすごいはいこちらマッスルスーツ me
ご覧くださいえまあちまう-25.5kg
フレンダー土壌これ筋力25kg でねあがるって事なんですよねヤバくないすか
これ見た時ついに品未来だなと思ったんですよもうこのマッスルスーツ
的に口を切るだけで筋肉画像
東京するので力は弱いとでもこれをつければ重いものが運べたリザに最も重いやつも
軽くもてるのじゃないかなと予想してますすいませまでよくわかんないけど僕最近出た
んでまず最新型フェス開けてみましょう
やばくできる筋肉って僕今のあばらの骨折れてるんでこっちのてだけものは持ったり
する結構きついんですよ華麗な思ってるんですけども覚え直すとけ
負担がかかっていたくてそんな時でもさては元の力フィアそれ以上の力が手に入ると
いうことからこれだったのかこれすごいぞおお
もうやばいね階でございまーすっ結構多いなぁ
歪みずだすごいなぁえちょっと待って近代すぎ大きさ的にガチっぽい積んでこれ
ちょっとあの怖いんだまだ説明書読みますそれでもめっちゃ簡単そうだろぜひ力みたい
に装着して使うみたいですね電池が以前つい
電池いらないっぽいぞこれ電池なった方ではさっそく中身を見てみようと思います
なんかも見てからかっこいいんですけど今
goo
何とも言えねぇよのマークとがめっちゃかっこいいですけども全然大サビで見るとああ
まあ清水ギュくださいですからダサくてもこれが俺の筋肉ですこれかければ25キロ
ぐらいパワーアップするんで傾げるびっくりですねおりますムズくなり募り今でもなん
か凄い凄いよでもそれがちぇるどが付いている自然観がチっぽいなぁ
かっこいいが声が声はずルックのようにしております
ダブル止めるんだろうなおおーー
おおーー
現時点でかっこいいがこここそ一主義ですねー
もうやばいです
あのう
阿散井ですこれがもうバット前にバーします
わーいボードボイさん40回ほど金ピン癖空気を充填しますねっ
これから俺なんかつからのほどポイズねーさん40階です
nds 順に良くなっていますずう年カ行
爆かける7開くかっけーじゃんこれねっ
て後ろが隙間のただベルトをまず成長しましたね
[音楽]
ええええええ
んん
何もわからんそれでもいろんな場所が好きもメンバーは大丈夫ですね
あーいけない位置からねちょっとはなるほどこうやってポンプに疲れていることによっ
てなんかここにすごい力が働きますとりあえずこれで今の状態で
よこれ前をこなしたんであのこういう感じでこれよく腰痛めてやつですねこの動きを
するとめちゃくちゃものが軽く持ち上げるんじゃないかみたいな感じらしいです
じゃあさっそくやってみよさあこれどうやって
[音楽]
ブーブー
ここです口からが語っててもはああいうよりもオレはーはー
細いすごい車次会へ
とって
すごいよ入ってもう運でお前さっきの時と比較しみてくださいこれ
ほらもう
おっ
俺強いんじゃないかも知れては2分すごいとちょっとしたままだったらもう指でもぜひ
てたぞ
んもうやばい混ぜ hey
なんか微笑ものを付けられるようになるというより重いものを持つあげるときに軽く
なるイメージですめっちゃなくこれからもの拳事が多い方とかつけたら結構いいんじゃ
ないかなって思っちゃいます
ヤバイよマジです
ああもうこれ完全もうバーッ
ああああああ
あー数なんでも持ち上げると
そしてここにある100万円札電車
[音楽]
ああああああ
ああっながら結構限界する塗りすると思ったらカブくらいです
そうで完了
[音楽]
まずどうなる状態だったら結構きつかったんですけども
これがどれくらい楽に用いられるが早速試してみようと思いますではあああああ
います
tan
ワーレイ
ん
teame
teal
me
ana あああっ
入りたい理由できる筋肉マッスル数分つけてみたんですけども
さすがに応募できるものはきつかったんですけどもそこそこ重いものとかだったら全然
軽くを持ち上がることが分かりました
今度はちょっとを持つの誰になりたいなの持ち上げる仕事がある方とかぜひ付けたら
本当に役立つような気がしましたぜひそういう何か物をたくさんがボブお仕事の方が声
をつけてみてはいかがでしょた
並にお値段は15万円です